cet autre rassemblement dénonçant la loi
dite contre le séparatisme à paris sur
le parvis des droits de l'homme
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines de
personnes et associations présents pour
dénoncer selon eux un projet de loi
raciste islamophobe et stigmatisant les
musulmans sont intitulés officiel projet
de voir confortant le respect des
principes de la république
l'assemblée nationale a achevé hier
l'examen des derniers articles les
députés même durci le texte est faible
sportives seront désormais soumis à un
contrôle on écoute certains de ces
manifestants qui ont prévu d'autres
actions au mois de mars
le 17 de cheveux mois la loi sera devant
le sénat en fait j'y vois un petit peu
une stratégie pas de bas déjà de couper
un petit peu les libertés de chacun il
ya un petit peu quand même une
stigmatisation voire beaucoup de
stigmatisation envers les musulmans
s'est un peu gouverner par la peur monte
un petit peu les uns contre les autres
et finalement se trouver des prétextes
facile pour mettre quelqu'un de côté au
nom aujourd'hui une offensive très clair
contre les musulmans et les musulmans de
ce pays la valeur si on cherche
aujourd'hui à territoires perdus de la
république c'est le parvis des droits de
l'homme qui juste à côté il ya bien
territoires perdus de la république
c'est le parvis des droits de l'homme
très concrètement puisqu'ils ont
aujourd'hui ce à quoi on assiste avec la
loi séparatistes c'est la remise en
cause de la loi de 1881 sur la liberté
de la presse
la remise en cause la loi de
l'enseignement de 1882 la remise en
cause de la liberté d'association 1901
la remise en cause de la laïcité de 1905
et c'est eux qui disent on défait nous
la république à chaque élection
présidentielle en particulier ce sont
les musulmans et les musulmanes qui sont
l'objet des débats mais lâchez nous
lâcher l'islam lâcher ceux et celles qui
vivent leur foi dans une intimité la
plus profonde